a great accomplishment that we started
receiving the 155 millimeter caliber of
artillery High Mars so that was a
victorious page in this war it was very
timely and it's very accurate and
precise
um armored vehicles we need them to
protect our people
there are all sorts of armored vehicles
bmps btr's tanks
and initially nobody even wanted to hear
about the tanks you were right but then
we found a moment we found a key and we
did something
last Autumn we saw that we are capable
to take back our land the occupation of
the harkiv region was
crucial
as well as her son's deoccupation
without that we wouldn't have been
successful
in receiving new types of weapons I
believe nobody in Ukraine couldn't even
fathom that we would have Patriots but
now uh we are receiving help
people believe in us there's a tank
Coalition this is a lengthy Hefty
process
this is the only weakness because time
means more people that we lose
and it's horrible to be losing our
Defenders so that is why
Expediting uh deliveries of weapons
Expediting delivery of not only air
defense But Country uavs Technologies uh
thank you
sea drones Etc
and also aircraft and our partners uh
they know that we want to use that to
protect our Sky to protect our uh people
and our infrastructure and that is why
we started working on it I had a meeting
with the prime minister of the United
Kingdom and actually this meeting is an
answer to the question
why the Ukraine stands the chance of
receiving
high-level aircraft the training with
uh
the UK is starting I had a meeting with
Polish prime minister Mr modovetsky
today we are looking into
training opportunities we are
negotiating
and they're um
three more European countries that we
can receive training
and aircraft from
it is also a matter of time because it
requires training
but this is what we're looking forward
to comprehensive protection of our Sky
Financial Times in the center
in the center please
um a very quick question you talked
about the Chinese peace proposal and
welcomed some element of it but I did
not mention at all the withdrawal of
Russian troops from Ukraine
given the views of the parliamentarians
does that mean the Chinese peace
proposal is dead in the water
you said it was going to be a short
question
well
um it's only a short question when the
answer is short well everywhere whether
it's China it's very hard to find a
short answer
I don't think that what China did was um
um an offer in it of itself
I believe it's only the state on whose
territory the war is taking place can do
that so we came up with an offer of our
own we came up with the peace formula
and well I think it was an important
signal that China
looks like is going to participate in it
that seemed as the reviews as of now I'm
seeing this as a signal only I don't
know what comes next it depends on the
further steps taken I want to believe
that China is going to side with the
idea of
Fair peace peace and fairness which is
our side I really want to believe that
China is not going to supply weapons to
Russia this is very important this is
priority number one for me and I'm doing
my best to prevent that from happening
it is very important for us
because you know it's better the way
things are for China now than in
Russia's Embrace because you know uh
there's this risk of the Third World War
[Music]
only after we see specific steps
will we be able to discuss them so far
I'm just seeing an opinion
the most important is territorial
integrity and territorial Integrity
implies withdrawal of Russian troops if
it's not there that means it is not okay
with us the way it is written now if
this is what's implied that there is no
withdrawal of Russian troops
prime minister of Sweden Carlton no
question
uh thank you then uh next an adult
agency please here
bunny president
thank you Mr President
can I ask a question in Russia president
Turkish president
[Music]
um
prepared for negotiations in Istanbul
and if Russian president were to wait
for you there would you accept that are
you from the Turkish
television Turkish news agency in Turkey
I just had a conversation with president
erdogan before our press conference we
had a nice conversation I expressed my
condolences uh you know that this is a
tragedy for us as well and the president
reached out to me and we sent a
Ukrainian Specialists to help
um
with this earthquakes situation
we sent cargo planes this hurts us too
as a country in war we perceived this
pain are as our own I'm very grateful to
president erdogan for his assistance for
his assistance with the grain trade met
with azove
regiment we managed to return some of
the men that could have been executed it
wasn't all of them but still
um president erdogan
has done some things that are very very
useful to Ukraine and he knows what I
think about what you asked about in your
question he knows about My Views I
reached out to him and we discussed it
even before the war and I told him
as well as I told that to many other
people
I said to him make sure Putin agrees to
sit at the negotiation table we cannot
to have a full-scale war happen and he
couldn't do it but now he thinks he can
but
we
no longer are able to go for that it's a
different person
Putin there's nobody to talk to
um
agency good evening Mr President if I
may I'd like to ask a question about
internal uh matters
internal processes as we remember in
2021 the National Defense and Security
Council
imposed sanctions against 100 ukrainians
the so-called Blacklist the U.S
Blacklist uh
those were the people that were
sanctioned there and there were a lot of
well-known businessmen high ranking
officials in that list but
um also some people were missing in that
list and they should have been there in
particular
um talking about
an official Edwards
now known as Nathan Rosenberg in 2021
the
U.S treasury imposed sanctions against
him but unfortunately he is not under
sanctions now and you know what kind of
person he is you know that he's been
anti-ukrainian he's prosecuted by our
Ukrainian law enforcement so the
question is
how can you explain that during the
ninth year of the war and second year of
the full-scale war people from
janukovych Circle still have businesses
in Ukraine uh it is
not sanctioned and one more well
just a minute let's let's answer let's
address this one first of all I'm not
quite clear
who you were talking about
every time the U.S
gave us a list of personal sanctions we
would mirror that and sanction them
and if the person you're talking about
is culpable then we will correct
ourselves
but you have to be
clear that we're talking about hundreds
of people that were sanctions I cannot
have information
and know about each and every one of
them well you could just give me the
materials case
we remember what happened and what
didn't happen you understand what I'm
talking about right I just wanted to
hear from you what happened exactly
please ask a question
um
was there a talk of replacing the
Minister of Defense resnikov in
particular Mr budanova
was a candidate but he wasn't appointed
due to some reasons well the reason was
that it's only the civilian that has to
be a minister of defense but he is a
military and so that runs contrary to
the law did you have a
conversation with the dress nikov and
buddhan about this situation well the
decisions that are making as a supreme
commander-in-chief
with regards to the security and defense
of our country is something that I do
not discuss publicly some of the
decisions one of those decisions is
security situations in some areas of the
country and some institutions I had some
ideas
um I'm not talking about the ministry
specifically but rather about the
infrastructure that is supposed to be
providing security
so I was thinking about making them
stronger with
different approaches and this was with
regards to
the border border regions of Ukraine and
temporarily occupied close to the line
of contact
uh bordering the occupied territories
and this is the context in which I was
discussing this matter
had I wanted to appoint
our main
intelligence official as a defense
minister we would have done it in line
with the Ukrainian legislation of course
I-24 Israel
thank you Mr President
regarding Iran you reportedly said last
week to our Israeli foreign minister
that Ukraine and Iraq and Israel share a
common Enemy Inside Iran in the Iranian
regime
now how does
Israel help Ukraine in curbing the the
Iranian military aid to Russia maybe
with intelligence maybe with NoHo and
also
you know these alleged Israeli strikes
on Iranian military infrastructures do
they actually help Ukraine
thank you for your question
for a long time during this War
I was really looking forward to Israeli
support not only from the public but
also from their political leadership
from various uh uh
institutions it was important
historically Ukraine has had amazing
relations with Israel and there were
various conversations at different
levels with different officials public
and non-public meetings in different
formats and in different places and it
was hard to change their position
because Israel has quite an easy
situation with the relations with Russia
Syria
Etc but I to really want them to be not
a mediator but I really want them to
choose a side Ukrainian side because I
cannot imagine Israel supporting War
Israel is a country that for dozens of
years has had a war so I couldn't even
fathom I know I have all the answers to
the question but unfortunately I will
not be able to share them
um here
I cannot jeopardize the Improvement of
Ukraine and Israel relations that has
begun SBS Australia and then SBT Brazil
after them
most of your allies have reopened their
embassies here in Kiev Australia has not
citing security concerns would you like
to see Australia's Ambassador return to
Ukraine and if he does not will it
affect relations between Australia and
Ukraine
foreign Martin
it's probably
it's so nice to hear a question that you
can say yes to
president I'll be very happy really I
have relations with Australia and and
really they they really helped us a lot
a lot and you know the very important
thing I I had big huge deficit with
armed vehicles and it's very important
yes moment and I don't want now to to
share all the information how many uh
we've got from Australia but anyway
we've got it and that is great that's
why to shake hand the ambassadors of
Australia I I I'll do it with pleasure
please come
come back
but on bushmeister
we need one more
Brazil
Mr President uh president Lula is trying
to gather countries outside Europe and
North America to facilitate to bring
both sides to the negotiation table uh
have you talked to him about this uh
proposal and you know that Brazil is
supporting Ukraine indeed when but has a
different approach on sanctions uh
delivery of weapons and ammunition what
do you expect from Brazil from another
American countries and when I'm going to
talk to president Lula Jaco
thank you
president
him invitations to arrive to Ukraine I'm
really looking forward to have a meeting
with him I would really like him to
assist me and support me with the
platform
for conversations with Latin America I'm
really interested in it
some of the steps of Brazil really of
supporting us our territorial integrity
and sovereignty that is that is for us
so important especially now yes and and
what what I'm just I'm just waiting
waiting for our meeting because he knew
eyes to us face to face I I will be more
understandable and I think Ukraine will
be more understandable that's it thank
you
from Netherlands please
Mr President thank you very much first
of all do you think in your lifetime you
will see President Putin inside an
international court for example in The
Hague the international capital of
justice and second you just met the
prime minister of the Netherlands
Margarita and you talked about the
delivery of f-16s
is it correct that's what we heard that
Ukrainian Pilots will be trained to fly
on the F6 f-16s for example by the
Netherlands
ah
well it appears that both the first and
the second question it all depends on
Mark root
I mean the situation in Hague
and the possibility of providing us with
aircraft
so I believe that it's important for you
Craig
that we have a very good personal
relations with Mark we're a very good
relationship with Margarita so it's it's
good for Ukraine
thank you okay we can proceed
looking what you've said
in the very beginning yes it's important
to well to settle this matter with the
accountability with Justice till the
very end I mean
having killed so many peoples many
civilians
you can't just have the situation at a
stop as we can see from a different
political
proposals like
searching for a way out look there's so
many people being killed but in here is
this leader of Russia leader of a great
country and they have to take
responsibility it's not a child it's not
a child who broke something and you can
simply forget that
and she needs and I think that's then
there is the different age when you need
to be responsible for the crimes
committee to stand trial
because you know there is a room for
jokes and uh that's something you would
like to watch with popcorn but that's
only if that would be funny but that's a
tragedy there's so many people
civilians killed and that is why you
would need to take responsibility for
what was done and I sincerely hope there
would be this responsibility
location where mh17 was down in Ukraine
as you know many Dutch people were on
board of that plane as other
nationalities
have we got a common goal
to get President Putin in front of
judges because Dutch investigations
found out that President Putin decided
to down
mh17 as he has decided to go into your
country and the Dutch photographer
wanted to give you this photo of the
sunflowers on that location of mh17
please keep your photo and we'll take it
after the press conference no after the
press conference please
I know you know I had so many different
presents from different countries and
always they said our bodyguards or
or Serie they said after
and you will see something after but I
didn't see yet
you know that's always like this so
thank you that you showed me I will
remember
I will remember it yeah uh
main strength of rooters
the strengths of the results and the
outcomes and the court railings I
believe that Hague and Netherlands and
Mark
this is something we've talked about
today that the Justice it's very hard to
to do
to have it but what's important is that
Netherlands always
uh gets things done till the very end
just as it was which mh17 so I hope the
same would be uh wisdom war that we
together will have this case towards the
court towards the fair uh now from Spain
and while you were waiting for the
microphone
it's getting darker
uh now and different countries are now
Illuminating their buildings
we can see Madrid while they will have
questions from Spain I would like you to
comment on the Spanish support that
yesterday our prime minister promised
that maybe he will send 10 times he will
consider sending 10 and which role can
Spain play in your goal to get closer to
Latin America
thank you
um
yesterday was it yesterday was that
yesterday that we had a meeting with
Pedro
it was yesterday indeed so yesterday we
had a meeting with Pedro Sanchez the
prime minister of Spain first and
foremost I want to say that we had a lot
of skepticisms in Europe
in terms of our candidacy and we met
Pedro he met Ukraine he got accustomed
with Ukraine so Ukraine has played a
great role he saw our country he saw
what we are fighting for his so the way
we're changing what's important that he
saw that institutionally we were running
in parallel I mean everyone has
continued to work all the banking
institutions the rest of the
institutions uh still working despite
the war and I think it's great that he
came in April it was among the first
leaders to arrive to Ukraine so we found
the relationship through him and I think
that the Spanish Society has understood
Ukraine better through him as well and
that was this attitude
your Society towards our uh internally
despite people
great internal displaced persons from
refugees if I'm not mistaken there's 165
000 ukrainians currently
hosted in Spain and that's a lot of
people he understands what we are
fighting for he supports Us in the EU
and I know that he's supporting us in
the security
matters within the NATO and from what I
can see that Pedro
we've already established some personal
connections with him he's sad that we
will help he said about increasing the
number of tanks and I think that's
that's his authority to to say how much
more tanks he can get for Ukraine we
talked about other equipment for Ukraine
we are grateful because we had some
previous uh conversations about uh Hawks
that's the air defense systems uh that
we were supposed to receive then some
other gearing ammunition uh to reinforce
the capabilities of our forces so
please
thank you president zielinski last week
the president of Poland had said that if
this war is still going on one year from
today there is a real danger that had
empowered Russia will invade another
state given how effectively you have
held back a Russian Advance with NATO's
help here in Ukraine is it even
conceivable that that Russia could
invade another state particularly a NATO
state
unfortunately I believe it's possible
and that might happen
I can I can give you an explanation
President
Putin needs to demonstrate successes and
victories
so there is not going to be a success on
the battlefield in Ukraine and he will
not succeed with the massive revenge in
Ukraine so he would need to demonstrate
success and everyone
understands that he can be he can have
success in Weak areas
it would be countries that was under the
influence of Moscow before the war or
during the Soviet times and it's better
to have some sort of conflict
or maybe some sort of
institution
you know the examples of model you know
that our intelligence have intercepted
the documents and
I have provided that well the moment I
have received this information I
transferred that information to the
president via sandal and there is
evidence that they wanted to replace the
leadership of the country now let's
think how they can do that how
so that's something that is happening
and they might be doing that they might
be developing this direction because I
don't remember when was the the meeting
it was on the 10th or on the 10th of
February there was the meeting in
Brussels now then that's the end of now
we have this end of February that's the
24th so it took them two weeks to find a
different informational attack so now
they're saying that the situation at the
borders or on the contact line
between the transnistria and Ukraine and
this area they're saying that there's
some misunderstandings some shorts big
for it and we have and
through the media that Ukraine is uh
planning to go to transnistria
because they clearly understand that we
respect the territorial Integrity of
Moldova
we believe that the territory of
transnistria is in fact the territory of
the independent country of Moldova and
they keep provoking us from the very
beginning of the war we had some shots
fired from transnistria and they wanted
us to oh well to go there and I told
Moldova to think about this into how to
settle this issue because that was the
very difficult situation that was in the
beginning of the war they tried to
provoke from different sides it was
informational hybrid war and steps being
made like that so I think that Russia
will try to have at least some sort of
success look a missile across the
Aerospace of Romania you know that and
then that Missile hit the Ukrainian
territory so they will keep on doing
steps like that I mean Russians and it's
better to prevent such capabilities
through sanctions and through making any
other steps we have a question maybe
from this area we have a question from
Romania
Mr President if
after a year of War even more you may
feel
that solidarity in other countries may
be diminishing can be tiring
what is your message to them thank you
Mr President
it's hard to talk about diminishing
support for Ukraine when you keep
showing everything and yellow and blue
in different parts of the world and I'm
very grateful for this you can't reduce
steps like that or diminish steps like
that you can't diminish work that you're
doing and of course you should not
reduce the support to Ukraine what I'd
like to to tell your societies maybe you
learned more about people from Ukraine
because you've hosted a lot of
people who are forced to leave primarily
women and children and I believe you
understand that the majority of them
they they're willing to return and by
helping Ukraine you're helping all of
them now if you will reduce that support
that's your support that's the support
of your integrity of your sovereignty
just now we told you that a missile
across your airspace but you're a native
member Nation but there was now God
forbid this missile will hit your
territory what the NATO will do they
will have to select what to do should
they preserve the unity in NATO and show
the strength
or
no
they would need to show the strengths
they would need to search for the
response options different ones I'm not
not deciding that we're not an a member
Nation but
I want my voice to be heard not by the
NATO member nations but the societies of
these countries these people The
Ordinary People
Ukraine has no right to fall
where did they have their KGB where did
they have their armed forces being
deployed now let's analyze where they
might be happening and you will
understand that this will be a chaos
this we cannot let this happen
now let's have a question from suspilner
please
huh
thank you this possibility Mr President
surely that seldoms of Ukrainian
children practitioners
this is an unprecedented situation
so I have a very simple question how and
when we will return those children are
we making some steps now what can we do
with the help of the international
organizations in our partners
thank you
we cannot take the children back by
force because we cannot enter the
territory of Russian Federation no
um Global institutions can do that by
force either uh they cannot do it either
because they don't have a mandate or
because Russia doesn't want to let them
in so what we can do we can exert
pressure there's going to be United for
justice circumference in leave
um and there will be
prosecutor Han invited high-ranking
leaders prosecutors International
organizations
and different solutions are going to be
discussed
sexual violence tribunals uh kidnapping
of children a crime of aggression
Etc
environmental matters so that's one line
of work secondly
Ombudsman is working we have a
coordination center that is working it's
very hard
[Music]
precious thing then they didn't steal
anyone they believe that they provided
shelter for those who were fleeing Nazi
the children will return home
and there will be accountability for
what was done so that's it at the moment
we are talking to the leaders about it
it is important that this matter has
become one of uh the most important in
the agenda it is being disgusted with
leaders in the European Union and I'm
convinced that the more we bring it up
um the more we'll be able to locate
those families the places where our
children are
the higher the chances
that this helps this is
not just a clear path of clear plan the
only thing that is certain is that we
need to deoccupy our land
is
um and I don't think we'll be able to
return 100 of the children as of now but
after our Victory the children have to
come back home ABC
thank you very much thanks for the
opportunity uh Mr President's opinion
polls in the United States are
suggesting that a growing number of
Americans believe that the US is giving
too much support to Ukraine what would
your message be on the anniversary to
those Americans thank you
I would like to thank the American
people
I would like to thank all of the
American people that are supporting
Ukraine the Congress the president the
TV uh channels the journalists and
everyone that has been supporting us
and that percentage of Americans as
you've mentioned is increasing
uh I can tell them only one thing
if they do not change their opinion
if they do not understand us if they do
not support Ukraine they will lose NATO
they will lose
um The Cloud of the United States they
will lose the leadership position that
they are joining the world uh that they
are joined for a very fair reason and
they will lose the support of the
country with 40 millions of population
with millions of children our American
children's any different than ours
don't Americans enjoy this the same
things as we do I don't think we're that
different
and I'm actually very happy that we have
bipartisan support but we keep hearing
those messages from time to time and
they're dangerous
uh there are political leaders that are
elected by people and if this issue is
raised those political leaders need to
be responsible and cautious because
people are looking at them who wants a
third world war would anyone
risk would anyone be willing to accept
that risk
the U.S is never going to give up on the
NATO member states if it happens so that
Ukraine due to various opinions and
weakened and depleting of assistance
uh uh loses Russia is going to enter
Baltic states NATO member states and
then the U.S will have to send their
sons and daughters exactly the same way
as we are sending their sons and
daughters to war and they will have to
fight because it's a nature that we're
talking about and they will be dying God
forbid because it's a horrible thing
I wish
peace and Ukrainian support to the
United States
tv4 Sweden
thank you Mr President I'm andish craft
from Swedish tv4 thank you for your
hospitality the people here are very
nice it's my first time in Ukraine today
Sweden decided to donate or send more
tanks and more military aid including
leopard tanks do you have a special
message uh something for the my viewers
the sweets today
I would like to thank them this is
I would like to thank them
genuinely I'm very grateful to Sweden
this is a very very powerful Aid package
we are enjoying amazing relations
with Sweden
with the Swedish leadership at various
levels
and we have some very high quality
meetings and negotiations and there was
a very good visit of the Prime Minister
um and we are about to reach a very
important decision
and it's hard work so I wouldn't want to
give details of it now because we all
need to prepare for that properly but
there's one thing I would like to say
you're doing
um
a great uh job uh it's a great decision
that you made to become a NATO members
and as you know Putin managed to unite a
lot of countries people in those
countries and I'm very happy for you I'm
very happy for Finland because it all
means NATO becoming stronger and NATO
becoming stronger is not about stronger
armies it's about better security so
that is why we want to be a member of
the alliance we want to be protected we
want to be helping others it's about
Collective Security so I'm very happy
um there are some things to work on
um and I'll be honest with you
you have to know that Ukraine is also
helping Sweden
thank you South Korea
jtbc if I'm pronouncing correctly
thank you Mr President I'm home at jtbc
from South Korea and I have one question
recently
narrow General Secretary General or the
South Korea to allow direct armed
support to Crane
has the Ukrainian government as South
Korea for direct-time support and could
you tell me why
well it would be a great thing if there
is a direct supplies of weapons to us we
would welcome that
yeah actually invited the leadership of
South Korea to come to Ukraine we were
working on a visit of our prime minister
to South Korea this was at the time when
it was very hard for me to leave the
country we have very much interested in
our relations
lateral relations that is very important
for us
and I think that we can continue it and
that's it that what what can I say there
are some details what we will what we
discuss with other countries about your
great country and I hope that I hope
that you will find possibilities to help
Ukraine thank you so much
thank you rather TV channel
foreign
thank you Mr President
first of all thank you for being with us
throughout this year very often
we uh here since the onset of the
full-scale war some public
forecasts some information
about uh
critical moments uh turning points I
don't think
that these are the terms and Concepts
that are used
at the Supreme commanders and Q but I
have to ask a question what are the odds
of
physically returning Crimea back to
Ukraine and what would be the
reintegration solutions for Crimea that
um
hasn't been with us for since 2014
everyone in Ukraine
really wants
the next step to be the final one the
Victorious one and very often someone
gets emotional when talking to the media
even governmental officials of different
levels they sometimes say that and
sometimes this and that is going to
happen why because everybody wants it to
happen everybody wants to bring back all
of our territories well we're all human
beings sometimes these are mistakes but
we won the victory so bad because we
deserve it we really want the war to be
over we really want peace we really want
to return everything to return our
people to bring our people back this is
what we want we want uh
our military our Defenders to come back
alive we want life life to return to
Ukraine it is not enough emotions do not
suffice
emotional statements are not enough
so regarding steps to be taken there's
only one thing that I can say it all
depends on us and I'm grateful to you
for being here for being here throughout
this year and it all depends on us
there are military steps to be taken and
we are getting ready we are already in
spirit and we are getting ready uh
as far as weapons are concerned as far
as foreign
brigades attack brigades are concerned
we are sending
um different people to train not only in
Ukraine we're sending people to train in
other countries because
there are different weapons and we need
to be ready
and
there will be fair
deoccupation steps and measures and we
can only hope that they succeed ABC
please first row
uh Mr President you've made clear your
belief that you can win the war this
year you've been clear about the
importance of support and the speed of
which it arrives I wonder if in a year's
time that Victory doesn't arrive and you
host a similar meeting like this
what do you think the most likely reason
for that lack of Victory would be and if
I could respectfully ask you to answer
in English I'd be very grateful
but yeah no no I can but but what the
question was what what about if I if we
can't I mean that if we can't if Victory
hasn't arrived for you by this time next
year what do you think the most likely
reason for that would be
um okay two so the most important thing
that the unity and that's true because
in the unity there is a huge support or
weak support anyway I mean that is
really
number one point number one if we will
not have are enough number of West kind
troops
enough uh weapon ammunition people will
not have of course will lose
a lot of people and they feel will be
losing a lot of people will lose you
know
moral
situation yes and it will be another
challenge for our country we will not be
so strong in the country in Ukraine and
that is the best the biggest problem
what can be I don't even don't want to
think about it that is the problem if
we'll meet on the 24th next year in the
24th of February and will be at the same
position where we are now
that is that is so that is drama
dramatic moment I don't want to think
about it
and you forget all your words
we have to be sure together we are
Partners we are from Britain
that
I see
us okay thank you so much we'll win
where our aircraft's typhoon
please ask my friend Rishi
um
Felix satellite
Mr President
um so you said that you appreciate being
straightforward so let me be
straightforward
um so I think right now
um
both Ukraine and Russia needs as many
countries as possible to stand on its
side so how do you convince the
countries that geopolitically a bit
remote from Ukraine
for example China for example South
Africa India to be actually on your side
there are countries that are
geopolitically far from Ukraine
in South Africa
so what can you tell them
how do you encourage them to side with
us
first of all I plan to meet with
seeing champagne and I think that would
be useful to our countries and to Global
Security we have a lot of we have a
significant Commodities turnover trade
with China
and well we are the countries that are
interested in preserving our economic
relations as far as I know China
respects territorial integrity
historic territorial Integrity which
means that China needs to do its best to
make sure that Russian Federation
withdraws from our territory because
that's what respect for territorial
integrity and sovereignty is would you
agree with me
yes
this is great
it's very good soft step forward
and it's great that we are on the same
page
you see I'm already start in public a
diplomatic relations here I think uh
live people people cannot be killed
would you agree with me
you can living people cannot be killed
civilians cannot be killed would you
agree with me
I believe that a nuclear power plant
cannot be occupied it is dangerous for
the entire world would China agree with
that
can you can you see the China agree
and I believe that we need to
respect international law and U.N treaty
this suggests that China
supports Ukraine's peace formula would
you agree with that
amazing
you see we have so many common issues
we have to speak
between us without somebody else
thank you so much
let's have a question from Argentina
then
maybe
this the journalists will say that this
country is also politically distant from
Ukraine we'll see thank you Mr President
I want to ask for it for a selfie but
maybe a exclusive interview would be
great could be after the discuss it
later
having said many times that this is a
war not only about territory but about
different two different ways of
understanding the world it's a war of
values
taking in count this difference in which
place do you think
in which place do you play the countries
of South America taking accountant
Argentina Venezuela Mexico they have
some roots or surbounds with Russia
and this I'm talking about the
government not the people which is
completely different so this is my
question in which of these two ways of
understanding the war do you place our
countries
and if this if there is any specific
specific support that you will expect
from from us thank you
thank you for the question
I have answered partially the questions
on uh South America we are interested in
uh having relations and understanding
what exactly is happening in Ukraine the
Russian Federation has uh made a large
informational campaign on the territory
of Latin American countries based on uh
their previous bounds we are interested
in you learning the truth the true
information we have shared values I
don't want to repeat about this we need
to talk really we need to talk and
Ukraine has to talk to all the countries
now to
all the countries that are not willing
uh to support the destruction of the
territories the destruction of the
states we have to talk because we're all
interested in Global Security because
there's so many that natural challenges
you can see what's happening around us
and therefore we have to think how to
preserve the humans the environment the
planetfully our new generations but
they shouldn't think of how to occupy
how to make aggressives types how to
wage Wars and how to create war and
create military conflicts so at this
point we're on the safe side same side I
just want us to know one another we are
lacking the embassies unfortunately we
weren't represented uh at all the
continents that we talk about now so
much and we talk a lot and this is not
to coincidence and answering your
question what what role what what
priority role is played We Believe U.S
equals would treat you as equals
as countries that have a priority in
terms of the relationship and building
relationship we can think not only about
the security we can also talk about
things that yeah
so much important to your business to
your people
uh any anything that you might be
economically interested in
now the question from Reuters
I think it's in in the other Corner
please
currently the United States
still have not provided Ukraine with
long-range weapons like
they have requested
um
makes the occupation more complicated
this year thank you for this question
conversation with the United States and
with the EU countries and that's one of
the reasons for me to to go to the EU
and to UK into the United States
you know it's hard to kind of realize uh
based on the informational space what
was in person what was the de-occupation
steps
why or where did they redeploy this 40
000 man why the East has become
reinforced they don't know this all
these details that the enemy was running
we were pressing them hard we were
making them Retreat from One bank to the
other bank and now they're deploying the
Weaponry on the other bank and
hitting our civilians and we have to
keep on saying and explaining that wrong
range weapons is about the protection of
our uh civilians because
many partners they have their own kind
of thoughts in terms of supplying
Atticus in such a powerful weapons and
by the way we've agreed with UK
but still it's a long-range weaponry and
we had to work a lot because there's
differing kind of
realization in terms of Ukraine needs uh
long-range weapons to fight or to hit
Targets on the territory of Russia
and there's uh thanks to telegram
channels there's different sources of
information there are institutions that
represented many countries
around the world I don't know why this
is happening some in some case that's an
informational policy of Russia like a
wave of disinformation or misinformation
now in some cases that's that's internal
fears that Ukraine could not be provided
without vaccine Americans or others
because Ukraine would be heating targets
at Russian on the territory of Russian
Federation but I want to tell you
publicly now we are working hard so that
people have understood that Russia has
deployed their Weaponry specifically at
these a certain range on the ocular
territory in order to kill civilian
population now we need to hit those
targets and defend our territory and
divide our people to hit the weapons of
Russians that are currently be located
on the territory of Ukraine we are
protecting our own population we have
herself I've explained a lot I've talked
about the banks I talked about the
details the streets the amount of
population that's a wonderful city with
a population of over half a million
before The Invasion and then when we've
deoccupied the people were happy there
were only 85 000 people
on the 85 celebrant someone was forcibly
deported others were killed we found
Graves someone laughed at the country
and when we deoccupied in a week
couple of southern people have returned
like what the Russia has done they've
deployed weapons on our territory and
started firing from the other Bank of
the river deeper knowing that our
weapons would not be able to hit them
they were killing civilians and now
there's people being killed so the
people were leaving the city and where
are they heating they're hitting bus
stations electricity potable water
supplies
gas uh Supply pipelines that's what's
happening I mean you try to go to the
hospital they're heating hospitals and
schools so that's what happened
and it's hard to find information like
that so even if you'd be reading things
like that you know how many spams are
there in addition to the correct
information that's why any person uh
different leaders they're reading their
get reports from intelligence but still
I mean trust that or not do you need an
emotion as well people would need to
have to understand this that would need
to receive true information from Ukraine
so that's why we need to talk to Africa
to let American different matters and
really we need to talk to you as to EU
so that we would be provided with the
wrong range weaponry
this is a challenge
another bigger challenge is the
aircrafts but we need to exert pressure
we need to keep on talking
thank you now the fifth Channel
hello
president Mr President thank you having
a chance to
uh this to to have this question by the
fifth Channel we were disconnected from
uh the news environment we're not
allowed to spread to operate but when
U.S and NATO were warning about
full-scale war you called upon
ukrainians to not listen to the
provocations now do you
kind of rethink uh
that shouldn't be the case and do you
think that what was your personal
mistake that the city is that the
citizens uh were not well prepared for
this War and what could be the
punishment for the ex had of the
security service of Ukraine and your
friend Ivan bakan do you think he's in
Ukraine and do you agree that because of
else's you
thank you for
for a report
it was good
I thought I was here on the 24th of
February I wasn't going anywhere
and uh I think that's important that we
have not lost the country
and yes it's thanks to the people of
United of Ukraine and that's thanks to
the Armed Forces of Ukraine and I guess
that's thanks to me as well a bit well
that's many people I think so I'm not a
hero but at least I've done something
since we're here in the deoccupied Kiev
in many of the deoccupied cities of our
country
maybe
I did something
we have NATO weaponry and we are
fighting
and we're not
signing any treacherous agreements like
Minsk agreements whatsoever
well that might be not something that is
comfortable for you to hear but I'm but
I'm grateful for your presence it's
great and I know that you will be here
still you also still
work that's wonderful but what's the
essence that we will win well
no matter how how what president uh what
sort of present do you have I mean with
the president was the former president
you did not wait so I'm grateful we're
to the journalists to the to soldiers to
to journalists and it's good that you're
on TV and it's good that despite
different accusations
that I'm the president of Ukraine that I
have destroyed the Russian presence in
the Ukrainian Parliament I have
destroyed the Russian channels in
Ukraine and I have destroyed the
oligarchs I'm sorry but one of those
oligarchs is the owner of your country
of your Channel
apologize of your channel let's have the
next question from the Latvian Channel
please
thank you Mr President we
we of course totally understand that
Ukraine is fighting also for us and we
are really thankful and appreciate that
but you also mentioned that Russia might
be interested in to attack NATO member
states so after all these very extremely
difficult year and uh bearing in mind
all your experience what would you uh
tell say advice to the Baltic states how
to live in this time despite that we are
NATO member states EU country but still
we are bordering Russia and we are we
have been threatened all of the time
thank you on the first day thank you
very much I really appreciate for all
that support the Baltic countries give
to Ukraine and you know that that you
know from the first days of occupation
and even before it we had such important
conversations and decisions from all the
Baltic countries especially you know I I
I I had meetings with gitanas now said
the president of
all the countries are on our side from
the very very beginning and when I was
speaking about we're beginning we are
speaking about
2014 so it's so important that we have
such friends strategic friends really
warm friends real friends that is
important and what can I recommend we we
always Ukraine will remember all that
support you've done and of course we'll
be together with you and I wish you
peace and we'll be will stay strong and
I I know that you will never be alone
all your people all your great nation
somebody said that politic countries
small countries maybe small country but
very big
big and great nation thank you so much
another question from the Polish uh
colleagues from TDP and if possible
could you please change the uh
uh system for hearing the interpretation
two brief questions you have a peace
formula we already know that and that
this is our conditions we'll start
talking talks with Russia but we know
that Russia is not willing to respond to
that now how far do you need to go in
order to make Russia
sit at the negotiations table or the
only way is to make Russians withdraw
their forces or maybe I don't know have
uh Ukrainian tanks in Moscow and since
we have our television channels until
their colleagues from many countries
people waiting for the safe skies in
Ukraine
Germany Romania Poland uh UK Spain now
what would you tell
any any message you would like to
address to the ukrainians to Refugee
stay in those countries since we have so
many journalists from those countries
well in the beginning
you thought about negotiations I think
that
that's something we've already talked
about this but still we need to be
strong in order to be strong in any
negotiations the Ukraine needs to be
strong on the battlefield now in these
cases though you can reach a therapies
under conditions of a civilized world
and I think that's the most important
thing if you Retreat if you are occupied
you are diminished and that's what
Russia has done by reaching Kiev they've
occupied a part of our country and
you've seen their response they've
provided ultimatums they were torturing
people so we know the results
when they're strong and we're when we
are occupied that is why I think that
it's important to be strong on the
battlefield that you will have a strong
position on the negotiation so let's
reach that step let's deoccupy as much
as possible this is very important to us
we will be stronger that's first now the
second
part now what can I tell to a Ukrainian
fellow citizens since we have so many
journalists or from different countries
and this room
something's happening
Okay so
much
without the citizens of Ukraine they're
currently located abroad our country
cannot be powerful
without you
fellow ukrainians with all the love
with all the effects words of gratitude
to all those countries that are hosting
you remember that your ukrainians you're
not Romanians no polish nor enjoyments
now with all due the words of gratitude
to those countries that are hosting you
they've done a lot they're supporting
you but I want you to know
that's your security that's your choice
that's your safety but I want you to
know that you're the very same
ukrainians as as everyone we are waiting
for the normal for the return of the
normal life so please return because we
need to rebuild our wonderful country
because that country is built for all
the people for all those who are
currently fighting and defending our
country and for all those who had to
leave temporarily ukrainians
well they are forever ukrainians even
though they leave the country for some
time now this is almost the end of the
press conference we still can take two
questions so let's have one from Ukraine
thank you for the possibility to ask
this question
the question on the security guarantees
security guarantees and Mark said that
hopefully they could be approved by July
and what are other countries uh
considering these the approve all of
their security guarantees any anyone
before the war and after the war
thank you very much we would like to
have security guarantees on our Pathway
to Nato we do not know when exactly
we're going to make it there it's not up
to Ukraine at the moment Ukraine has
shown its Trends on the battlefield
and uh it also showed that our public
supports it regarding challenges we
really need security
guarantees we are negotiating that with
the EU countries with the UK with the
United States of America
so this is the circle of those that
we've talked about it at the moment when
that is going to happen I do not know
um
Mr President
the stolen childhood the kidnapped
children were already discussed today
and I would like to talk about family
this year has changed a lot for millions
of families and it probably affected
your family as well uh first lady has
been referred to uh as by International
observers as a symbol of
resilience and her voices heard at
various International platforms so um my
question is how did this 365 days of
full-scale invasion changed uh your
relations with your family if you could
answer that this is the last question so
I would really like to hear something
about
something personal
the
final question and the hardest one I
love them I love my family I like my
wife
my children are the most important
people for me
I do not get to see them often
my parents
I don't have uh
any opportunities to see them
I'm very proud
of my wife
yeah
I know what kind of person she is and I
know that she is doing everything she
can for the sake of
children and the country and of course
it's a great thing for her to do
something for the sake of me well on a
joking note they're all in my heart of
course
and I was actually honest with you when
I said that this is the the hardest
question and I'm having a hard time
finding words the most important thing
is not to let them down
the most important thing is to make sure
that my children are proud of me
and I am happy that they're in Ukraine
that they go to Ukrainian universities
it is very important for president of
Ukraine
for the incumbent president or for the
previous president when you're a
president of the country in uh War you
have to be here because the men and
women are dying here and it's important
for your wife and your children to be
here I cannot order them to be here
what's important is that
they are this kind of people and I'm
very lucky to have this family in this
country
I can see there are a lot of questions
but unfortunately two and a half hours
were not enough to address all the
questions but this has been a very hard
week and a very hard day so we have to
wrap up now thank you everyone